je vous donne un exemple 1 8 million 400
mille personnes sont des gens de
l'étranger qui sont sur le territoire
quelle que soit leur nationalité et sur
ces 8 millions 400 mille personnes nées
à l'étranger nous en avons 12 millions
400 mille qui bénéficient de prestations
sociales voilà donc là encore une fois
quand on a dit ça on a compris qu'il y
avait un problème
[Musique]
e
malheureusement le gouvernement macron
ne semble pas avoir pris la mesure du
phénomène de la fraude aux prestations
sociales par exemple savez-vous que dans
un pays de 67,1 millions d'habitants ce
qu'est la population en france nous
comptons
75 millions 300 mille assurés sociaux
qui sont pris en charge qui sont ces 8
millions et qu'elle de personnes prises
en charge en plus que des gens qui sont
censées exister en france effectivement
je démontre un rapport de la cour des
comptes à l'appui et rapport de la
commission d'enquêté de l'assemblée
nationale que et bien la situation est
catastrophique on a le phénomène des
cartes vitale active en surnombre ces
cartes vitale qui permettent aux gens de
consommer des soins alors que
normalement il ne devrait plus avoir de
droits ouverts alors ce ne sont pas des
fausses cartes vitale ce sont des vrais
car dit anne sauf que les droits
continuent d'être ouvert donc de
permettre des remboursements alors même
que les gens ne sont plus censés y avoir
droit vous allez découvrir également un
l'étendue de ce qu'on appelle le
tourisme médical vers le nombre de gens
qui réellement chaque année se font
rembourser des soins par l'assurance
maladie comparé au nombre de gens qui en
théorie un consomment des soins chaque
année puisque vous savez que tout le
monde ne va pas chez le médecin chaque
année tout le monde consomme pas des
soins et là qu'on ne vienne pas dire que
ce sont des gens qui viennent simplement
pour consommer une boîte de doliprane
parce qu'on sait très bien que si
quelqu'un vient faire du tourisme
médical en france ce n'est pas
simplement pour acheter une boîte de
médicaments à 5 euros
il est évident que les gouvernements et
la haute administration ont peur de ce
sujet et notamment du sujet de la fraude
aux prestations sociales on l'a bien vu
au moment de la commission d'enquêté de
l'assemblée nationale en 2020 puisque
même le ministre des affaires sociales
un monsieur vers on n'est pas allés
devant la commission denquête il n'a pas
témoigné il ya trouvé un prétexte il n'y
est pas allé on a bien vu un certain
nombre de hauts fonctionnaires qui
étaient très gênés aux entournures quand
il était entendu parce qu'ils étaient
obligés de prêter serment c'est à dire
comme cela qu'on a pu avoir un certain
nombre d'informations qui ont permis de
découvrir l'étendue de ce cartel des
fraudes en matière de prestations
sociales un autre des problèmes
concernant la fraude aux prestations
sociales c'est que c'est aussi un sujet
étrangers immigration je vous donne un
exemple 1 à 8 millions 400 mille
personnes sont des gens nés à l'étranger
qui sont sur le territoire quelle que
soit leur nationalité et sur ces 8
millions 400 mille personnes nées à
l'étranger nous en avons 12 millions 400
mille qui bénéficient de prestations
sociales voilà donc là encore une fois
quand on a dit ça on a compris qu'il y
avait un problème moi ce que j'évalue
c'est moitié-moitié d'accès moitié un
problème d'immatriculation
anormal de gens qui sont nés à
l'étranger soit disant et moitié de gens
qui sont nés en france mais qui
effectivement pour x raisons sont encore
dans le système alors qu'ils ne le
devraient pas on peut penser à des
expatriés etc
je considère qu'au regard de l'enjeu la
masse financière la priorité doit être
la lutte contre la fraude aux
prestations sociales et notamment la
sécurisation de l'immatriculation et
donc pour régler ce problème là la
solution c'est de sécuriser l'identité
de réimmatriculer tout le monde avec la
biométrie comme ça on évitera les
doublons d'identité ça permettra aussi
de vérifier que des gens qui ne sont
plus sur le territoire national et donc
normalement ne devrait plus bénéficié de
baisses de prestations avec ces gens là
sont sortis du système bref c'est une
remise à plat et vous verrez que si on
fait ce travail là et qu'on sort du
système 4 5 6 millions de personnes
comme par hasard les dépenses elles vont
chuter voilà ça c'est mathématique il ya
quelques années le conseil
constitutionnel avait
évoqué ses réticences à ce que la
biométrie soit utilisé pour la lutte
contre la fraude
personnellement je ne comprends pas
pourquoi on ne pourrait pas utiliser la
biométrie pour lutter contre la fraude
aux prestations sociales c'est quand
même c'est notre argent on nous vole cet
argent c'est que les et l'identité des
gens qui sont des bénéficiaires ça me
semble un minimum moi ma position c'est
de dire qu'avant d'aller augmenter les
taxes et des impôts des gens ou de
baisser les prestations retraite les
prestations sociales etc il faut d'abord
aller chercher l'argent dans la poche
des fraudeurs puisque si on stoppe à la
fraude on pourra continuer à augmenter
les impôts de manière exponentielle on
aura toujours ce problème devant nous
où
[Musique]